[Music]  I think it tastes neither like a beer or  like a wine traditionally it sits  somewhere in between you like a beer but  you wanted something a little stronger  and I would say you probably really  respond to need it's not quite as sweet  some people would think it is especially  the stuff I make  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  it's oftentimes simplistic in terms of  its ingredient list but it's the highest  quality of those ingredients and it's as  complicated as those ingredients can get  [Music]  there's this idea within the home  brewing community oftentimes that like  you can be the best Brewer possible just  by perfecting your craft I don't think  that you can really ever become the best  at brewing I don't think that that's the  idea I think you can become more wise I  don't think that you can become all wise  if you name something something like  that you can strive after it and you  work towards it every day  [Music]